you're seeing this return of the liberal
establishment's always progressing to
the left
and now it's fashionable in some
quarters to say that the solution to
this is not conservatism
but but true liberalism so what they'll
say is there's a difference between
leftism and liberalism and leftism is
bad
but liberalism is good and you know
conservatives we're the true liberals
and the liberal left you know they're
actually illiberal because you know they
want to censor you or something like
that
matthew mcconaughey who is increasingly
talking about politics and seems like a
nice enough guy you know he seems
somewhat conservative or at least
centrist compared to his colleagues in
hollywood
he he articulated this point on a
british morning show he said that the
answer is not conservatives
or conservative thought what we need to
do is just all be liberals
you need liberals
what i don't think we need is the ill
liberals and what i don't think that
some
liberals see is that
they're often being cannibalized by the
ill liberals
now you know there are extremes on both
sides
that i think are unfair that i don't
think are the right place to be
the extreme left and the extreme right
completely illegitimize
the other side um the liberal and the
conservative side which we need in
certain places they
the two extremes illegitimize those
those two sides
um or they exaggerate that
that side's uh stance into an irrational
state that that makes no sense and
that's not fair when either side does
that um
you know we're we're gonna we've the
where where the water lines gonna land
on this freedom of speech
um and what we allow on what we don't
and where this canceled culture
goes where that water line lands is a
very interesting place that we're
engaged in right now as a society of
trying to figure out because we haven't
found the right spot
okay right there i don't even need to
refute matthew mcconaughey's argument
because mcconaughey refutes it himself i
think this is a
good impulse i don't mean to beat up on
matthew mcconaughey i think he has
all good impulses and i just think this
is
an idea that a lot of people have i've
had this idea myself
when they think about politics and it's
just half baked
the idea that look we don't want
conservatives
telling people how they ought to behave
and we don't want leftists telling
people how they ought to behave and we
don't want conservatives telling people
that maybe they shouldn't say that thing
and we don't want leftists telling
people maybe they shouldn't say that
thing what we need is
true liberalism but then at the very end
he says and what we need to do in this
free speech issue is just figure out
exactly what sort of things we're going
to tolerate and we haven't figured out
exactly what that is yet you say wait a
second i thought you were calling for
liberalism i thought you were calling
for
let everybody say what they want let
everybody do what they want
but then you're recognizing you need a
standard the reason that this argument
that we need to be liberal not illiberal
that the illiberal right is just
terrible and the liberal left is
terrible and we all just need to be able
to say and do whatever we want all the
time
the problem with that argument is that
has never existed anywhere in history
and it never will that is a utopian idea
the idea that there can be no boundaries
on what we say or do
and that there are no consequences to
people's behavior and that if you
act virtuously or you act viciously it's
all sort of the same and has no
political consequence
that is a utopian ridiculous idea that
is meant for freshman year philosophy
class
or staying up ripping a bong at three in
the morning in your dorm room saying ha
ha man you know wouldn't that be cool
if it feels good do it that's not how
politics
actually works you know some people now
call this kind of idea
libertarianism and i think that does a
disservice to serious libertarian
thinkers
but inasmuch as this is libertarianism
it's got the same problem that socialism
does you always hear the social say
true socialism has never been tried true
communism has never been tried
well true liberalism has never been
tried like this
because it can't be because you always
need some kind of a standard and i
actually give the left credit
for recognizing that isn't it weird that
any in all liberal societies
every single where in the west where
this sort of thing has been tried and
even some other places that have adopted
liberal societies they all seem to just
always trend toward progressivism and a
kind of leftism
and there's no way to stop it in that
weird is that just like a weird
coincidence
but if we just try it one more time
that'll work no maybe we need to
rethink how we're talking about this
maybe maximizing
individual autonomy is not a totally
coherent end goal
of politics